welcome everyone to episode 20 of play
watch listen i'm alana i'm joined by
austin
troy and mike all of whom work on video
games and today
we are talking about uh the
recent i guess reveal that nba 2k which
is why i chose
basketball background um is going to be
70
more expensive on next-gen consoles the
idea behind this specifically
is that 2k is the one who's going to
break gaming's de facto 60
ceiling asking 70 for next-gen nba 2k21
uh do you guys think this is going to be
because everyone's kind of assumed this
is going to be something everyone else
is going to do
do you guys think this is going to set a
trend or is this just a one-off
or just 2k potentially depends on people
buy it
i mean that's that's that's it like with
right things cost as much as people
willing to pay right like if they
if they don't see a dip in terms of unit
numbers
which would i mean they're going to
anyway because it's a it's generation
change so that's what that always
muddies the water a little bit but they
will have their estimates and
if if they think enough of the audience
come with them on that price change
they'll they'll stick to it you know
it really is a vote with your wallets
kind of situation right like right down
the line
i feel like people will i don't think
that's going to be
sure we can't keep people from their
video games at this point
and there's a lot of games that already
have a way higher price than that when
you
factor things like season passes and all
the stuff that people are already
selectors edition yeah i mean like i
remember when when star wars battlefront
came out
i just thought i it just it sold me so
so hard and i went and did the whole
[ __ ]
top of the line season pass it was like
100 bucks and i paid for 15 minutes
and got my ass kicked so hard that i was
like i'm remembering why i quit playing
games like this a long time ago like
tribes and stuff that i used to be so
into
and then and then uh because keyboard
and mouse i can hold my own but with a
with a freaking uh playstation
controller i just suck
and so yeah so yeah i i shelled up a lot
and then
and then it hurt um and i remember
thinking this is the most i've ever
created i think
kind of shady because uh you could buy
all of them without knowing what they
were and then they would announce what
they were like months and months and
months
apart and i felt like asking people to
buy something that they don't even know
what it is is like hey i'm very against
pre-orders in general
stop doing it but uh why
like especially when it comes to it i
just never think
why you're giving uh a
multi-million dollar corporation money
for a product that isn't even complete
yet correct me if i'm wrong though i i
want to comment also on the on
the the price thing too but two
two-parter
um mike bethel truth or not um
if if there's like a high level of
pre-orders for something
then that could potentially mean that
the team
maybe the budget gets increased so
they're able to do more things and they
weren't originally
or that their scope of the game could
increase or
that their timeline could increase and
stuff like that based upon hey your
pre-orders are
a harbinger for where we think your
ultimate sales will go so
that's not just like giving a
multi-million dollar corporation but
it's actually benefiting the dev right
yeah i mean it's similar to create a
conversation of like is that the
player's job to like help me in my
day-to-day kind of
uh thing no it's not right exactly yes
but but you're right no it does it does
factor in and you will often find yeah
we'll get more time we'll get more
marketing support
and i think players often will be like i
don't care if they're getting more
marketing support it doesn't really
matter but
obviously the more people play a game
the more money goes into it
theoretically the more kind of dlc
sequels or
that kind of you get more of the stuff
you like but i'm kind of i'm i'm kind of
with a lot of
like it's kind of not the player's job
to help me out on that like
but you also said vote with your wallet
right like sorry
you said vote with your wallet that's
that's voting with your wallet that's
like absolutely
voting with your wallet i think if
people are like yo cyberpunk looks
awesome i really love this team i really
want to see them be successful
um i want this game to be the best thing
ever that what i've seen so far
i am willing to in faith because we do
the same thing you don't know if that
game is going to be good when you buy it
the timeline of when you
show your act of faith is irrelevant
because either you do it
six months before a year before two
years before
or the day of release you still don't
know if that game's going to be good and
you buy it regardless
and then you can get rid of it if you
want to or at least you used to be able
to
um i i think that and i don't want to
suppose that like digital editions you
know collector's editions because that
become
became kind of the new trend it's like
you can get the
digital collector's edition so you may
not get a statue or a steel box but
you're going to get some extra bonus fee
in-game features because you got a
collector's edition
and maybe you did a pre-order of that as
well i don't want to assume that there's
no cost to the dev for that
because somebody still had to even if
it's just a skin
someone still has to do that like so
there there is a cost to that as well
but it's not a hard cost like
going to triforce or um
whoever the other collectible um why am
i trying to blank who's that elana you
should know this
gentle giant i've done a couple i don't
think triforce does them anymore you
know yeah i think they're done that's
why as soon as i said that i was like
those guys haven't been doing this for
like years
but what's the main one there sideshow
um
you know if you do like that the joel
nelly statue back there or something
like that then
there's there's a much bigger high cost
um and a hard cost
to that but back in the day
cds cost x amount it was there was a
fixed price
for when a cd came out same thing for a
dvd or a blu-ray there's a standard
price for that
uh if it was a new release it was going
to be 24.99 if it was a cd it was going
to be 12.99 that's the cost of a cd
games by and large have always been the
same way it's always been that 59.99
that's it's 60 bucks for that game and
we've even
included that in our vernacular that's
not true now
what's the price of a game
which game which platform are you
talking
free 99 cents 399
69.99 49.99 there's all there's there's
like this huge open market now for
prices
so game prices increasing some game
prices increasing
is logical and like you said people
either buy it or they won't
but people are already spending that
money but if i don't want to pay
69 bucks for a console game i'm not
wanting for titles
for less i can get other games for less
well i think that's why nba is a very
good test because it has a built-in
guaranteed audience annually
right it would be a great fifa 2 um
which i think i still feel like fifa
should be free to play and it's crazy
but
it gets away with that many sales in a
year oh it's nuts
uh because fifa's also just like done so
much damage to ea and that they're like
why haven't you made fifa money how can
we figure out how to get this game to
make fifa money and i feel like that's
why we lost dead space
but anyway mike do you think that
there's any justifiable reason
um that uh a next-gen game would be
ten dollars more expensive like is there
any development
reason that that is or is it literally
just marketing i mean develop games cost
a lot more to make nowadays than they
did
at the turn in the last generation but
there's two versions right
so they have it's only the next gen
version that is
seventy dollars the current gen version
is still sixty dollars right yeah it's
transition so you
this we see this quite a lot actually
kind of internationally like it varies
from country to country but you'll often
see like generation changes where the
price increase comes in
i think in the uk there was one with
like xbox 360. i remember that was
the last time possibly in the uk that
this went through a big jump
but yeah games games cost a lot to make
and especially with players expectations
of how big a
aaa game is right the kind of amount of
content you're asking for
does take time to make it does take
money and crucially as well
graphics you know at that level when
you're going for that photo realism
there is like this exponential growth
and there's things we're doing that's
that's better you know we talked about
like the stuff that's happening in the
unreal engine for example that where
there is stuff that makes this stuff
more efficient but it's still
you know a great number of artists who
are actually required to produce this
stuff so
it does make sense i'm kind of i kind of
agree with troy in that
we already have variable price i know
it's rare it happens like once in a
person
but like it's we have variable price in
the indian like my games
are five dollars ten dollars twenty
dollars like different games we we
bounce all over the place and
indie games in general do that and then
you have something like um desperados
that came out where that is
that's like a 50. that is like that to
me is like that's that's
interesting in that it's almost a triple
a price for a game that is decidedly
indie
because it's such a niche game such a
cool title people like me who love that
game and love that genre but there's not
enough of it
we will swarm to that and pay a premium
for it
aaa has locked into this fixed price and
it feels a bit
kind of like the cds as troy says it's
also like uh cinema tickets
like we we have locked into this kind of
generic
cost for a triple a game and there are
fundamental differences in terms of how
much
even the difference between like how
much last of us two costs versus ghosts
of
tsushima right those are going to be
very different budgets very different
scales of production
they they might be different amounts of
time there will be different scales of
teams
um cd projekt red with cyberpunk i i
think i'd
start crying if i saw the budget for
that game like it's
but we're all we expect them to come out
in a box with exactly the same price and
exactly the same cadence i think
aaa would do well to kind of have more
variety and just acknowledge like you
know what this is
this is going to be a 50 game this is
not at the scale you're expecting
and likewise no this this is cyberpunk
you're gonna be playing it for four
months
it's a hundred dollars like i know i can
understand the audience not liking that
idea but having that variety in that
range
i think probably we benefit from that
more i think we'd be disappointed by the
by less you know indeed less aaa games
if they were
more variable we'd get more aaa games
cheaper and then those games that were
really worth it and that we
you know we'd read five reviews of we
knew they were brilliant we make the
investment in
i'd love to see more i think more
variety would be better for all of us i
think that you're raising a really
um interesting point off of that though
that
we project the value based on the price
we see being asked for
and so like if if let's say ghosts of
tsushima cost
a lot less for whatever reason than the
last of us
uh you know in a hypothetically and so
they were charging
45 versus 60. i think there's a certain
knee-jerk subconscious of like
ah that's they didn't it's not as much
of a game
you know there's not like it should be
the other way around like i don't think
you should charge for games based on how
much they cost to make
like that's not how that's not how any
other industry chooses its prices
yeah like cinema tickets are like across
the board it's like i don't care
well but it's also about value right
like if you're if i'm my point
it takes me the same amount of work like
if i'm running a restaurant right
i can be a i can be a top tier
restaurant with some higher costs
or i can be like you know a cheap
takeaway place with much lower costs of
running
but the price differential between those
two restaurants is not going to just
match the differences in the cost of
running the thing
i'm going to be able to charge twice as
much three times as much four times as
much five times
ten times a hundred times as much in the
more expensive place because of the
perception of value
yeah yeah if ghost of tsushima is is
perceived as a bigger game than last of
us two
who cares how much it costs to make like
that's that the player doesn't care
that's that's not valid to them
we should be making we should be
charging based on the product we provide
and that's how we do we've
we've made games is this true yes we've
made games
at ten dollars i just have to always
catch myself i think we've released
games that ten dollars that cost more to
make
than games we made them we sold at
twenty dollars because the twenty dollar
game
we know that there's a there's more need
for it there's more desire there's a
perception of value
and also the ten dollar game we need to
sell to more people because of xyz so
there's
lots of yeah exactly well that's very
loud
that very last point was going to be the
the kind of slight pushback of
of there's always that dialing up and
down between
what's better in this instance more
customers at a lower price point or
fewer at a higher price point because
people will fall off with every
dollar increase like alana was saying
you know with especially
territories outside the us um you're
gonna
you're gonna find a much greater
variability of what people are willing
to
stomach in terms of costs you know the
u.s seems to
be able to broadly sort of inflict
a lot of heavy prices and still
and still make a return on it um but but
but you know it's like if i had the
choice between
marking it lower quote projecting less
value but knowing that i could reach
people
in australia in you know
the whole globe that for me you know
that's almost always the direction i
i tend to lean uh and so but i'm always
told as a result like
when i sell my albums for example that
tends to be i tend to mark them lower
than a lot of my colleagues and i'm told
you're devaluing your work and i say
well i'd rather it be
i'd rather more people have the chance
to hear it like you know what i mean
that that seems like if i may
um something that occurs to me also is
not
it's not just sales that will
determine the success of a game it's
also the profitability
so let's say that there's a game that
sold a gajillion copies but it
made a gajillion dollar it cost a
gajillion dollars to make
the the price of the game or how much it
sold that to that publisher is gonna be
like
so the game that like you you take like
an inside
where it's like about i have no idea
what their budget was
but we always come back to that as like
it's a perfect game or whatever but
as far as like cost to make versus
profitability that's what's going to
keep that studio
being able to make more games has
nothing to do with the fact that they
sold at 69.4929
whatever it's the cost versus
the profit and that's what a publisher
is gonna be able to go we will give you
more dollars
to make more games also the other factor
here is lifetime right and that's that's
the big one that different companies
handle differently like you've got a
company like nintendo that will release
a game
and you're never going to get a nintendo
game cheaper than the day it launches
like
really eventually maybe yeah but it's it
you're right i haven't thought about it
but nintendo games really don't go on
sale a lot never
and that's but they've done that and
they've done that for decades and that's
why
you know you don't wait on a mario you
don't go oh it's
you know it'll be it'll be cheaper in
two months because you know
no i'm always gonna have to pay that if
i want the nintendo quality experience
i'm gonna pay
that's you know that's a luxury good
right whereas if you're
if you're buying any kind of aaa game
you know there's a very different arc
that game's gonna go through same with
indie games
um and also from studio to studio you'll
know oh i've seen
like ubisoft right they do very quick
steam sales so you know if you're a
person who likes ubisoft games
if i don't care about this one so much
i'll go i'll get it cheaper in a couple
of months
we've found it we've found it even down
to franchises so we've with our we did
um the circular games
and we've never discounted below 20 off
a circular game
specifically because we want to say to
the audience no these games are five
dollar games we're not gonna you're
never gonna be able to get this game for
a dollar
we're not going that low with that we're
creating that expectation
um and that works well for us because
people are more willing to buy because
they've seen that historically and they
understand the context of what they're
seeing
but i don't begrudge anyone who goes
that indie game is obviously going to be
much much
on that same line of thinking i think
it's important to educate
the the player to go this is what our
games cost and this is what you can
expect to help manage that expectation
to also
uh weekend or whatever opening week of
this game we wanted to do a certain
amount of numbers if you want to wait on
this game
we've we've set a precedent that's that
shows you after five months
we typically have made whole enough and
we're going to discount it so maybe you
want to wait
and then we get some extra bonus sales
far after when we're making our next
game
the thing that i don't feel um by and
large
consumers have been educated on is that
used games is a cancer
to the entire system
because i understand from a from a
buyer's standpoint steve jobs had a
quote
where someone was when he first launched
itunes
um he was interviewed and he goes if you
don't give
people a legal alternative
of course they're gonna do napster i'm
creating itunes
as an alternative because i see that
napster
will kill this industry and it did it
completely fundamentally it was the o.j
simpson
and chasing being chased into white
bronco once that happened on tv we never
looked at tv the same
way and once courtroom drama became like
that's all we do that's why all of those
shows became because
we were enthralled by seeing somewhat a
celebrity
going through a murder trial on tv and
that changed the course of tv
napster changed the course of the music
industry fundamentally
from the 2000s on so
the used game industry does not benefit
anybody but that specific retailer
whether it be
gamestop or best buy or walmart or
whoever
none of that money goes back to the
developer
um or the publisher also people who
can't afford to buy
something i agree but it's incumbent
upon
the the video game industry not the
retail industry but the video game
industry to go
how do we meet consumer demand when they
say i won't buy this game for 69
i won't buy this game for 59 i wait
until it goes
29.99 used or i have a value when i go
i'd no longer want to play this game
i'll give you this game for that game
or at least a discounted price on that
game and i think the answer you're not
saying you're not saying there are
you're not saying used games are a
cancer you're saying they're
they're showing a need which we should
cater to better that's what you're
saying that's a far better
characterization of it but regardless
the i mean i feel like
that's sort of what game pass is
providing i think game passes i don't
know if that's the answer because that
could then
shift all of the responsibility and and
pass on that
terminal illness to devs because
people studios can't be sustainable it's
gonna you're gonna have to be like an
assimilation
and it goes from this free market to
like the only
only studios that can survive are the
ones that are bought and sold or bought
and paid for by
a studio by like a a publisher and you
no longer have that it's it's
creates this huge valley between aaa
first party studios
and independent studios where i can only
make this kind of game and i can only
make this kind of game
because the cost so it's if you want to
support
games you have to be able to buy
directly from the developer publisher
it depends for me on the publisher there
are some publishers where i would think
that that
was true but then there are certain
publishers where
bobby kotick's getting millions of
dollars a year and well not anymore but
was and uh taking all of that home and
then being like oh
used video games when you have so many
games with micro transactions that are
profiting even more on top of that 60
buy-in and you're taking all of that
money home and your board of directors
is [ __ ] loaded i feel like it's a
little bit hard to say
oh this burden is on the industry and
these publishers can't survive without
it when we know that some of them
definitely can and do with flying colors
so i feel like it depends
on the studio i'm drawing a delineation
though between developer and publisher
publishers will always be fat cat money
makers always and i'm not trying to like
demonize them or vilify them but i am
saying by and large
understand that they are a miserly
stepfather that gives
their their children the allowance um
and
it's completely dependent upon the
relationship that they have as far as
how much allowance they're given
but what i'm trying to say is if a
publisher goes sorry you underperformed
you're like
there's milli we have anecdotal proof to
show that there's millions of people
playing our game it's like yeah but they
waited until six months then they went
into the bargain basement and
nobody's getting that money but best buy
but i well so i want to actually i'm
just going to
please if i'm wrong building on your
point this is building on your point
troy this isn't disagreeing with it for
sure
yeah i think it's i think but i think
there's an additional thing here which
is
there's two things with with making
entertainment one is
obviously making money from the
entertainment two is
having the entertainment be something
that's known so you can start building
franchises and stuff
i know of lots of people who've say
pirated my early games or bought
something i say secondhand which i don't
profit
from at all right but they become a fan
they become converted and then that's
where i get them later
that's exactly what i was gonna bring up
i feel like that never comes up in these
conversations that like
i obviously would like to get paid for
everything and
live comfortably and have my team live
comfortably obviously
but i'll take a player i'll take a fan
like
a fan is someone who bluntly and
cynically i can make more money from
later you know always
now i i think that that's true i think
that that's um
there's a lot of musical parallel to
that you know that i think that's
i think that's a lot the basis for a lot
of bands sort of
saying we will essentially give our
music away for free
online or effectively free
through spotify and that kind of thing
um
in exchange for the loyalty of folks
that would show up and
buy a t-shirt or go to a concert uh
because that's where the market has
shifted to the you know the experience
and to me
that the used market you're i don't see
i don't i think it's too harsh to call
it a cancer
because like alana said there's it's
providing a need
that um is
sort of unique uh that i don't know that
a game pass or something
could potentially take care of in the in
the way like in your steve jobs analogy
um but if you know if someone discovers
your game
and then they they sign on you know
that's
that's on the whole a net gain for sure
plus i remember once i was approached by
a
tech company i'll leave it there a
non-game making company
asking if i was interested in
collaborating on some music related tech
r d
and i said i have a bunch of really
wacky ideas
um but uh they are
um not likely to make you any money
i said i have some ideas that are
probably going to be a little out there
and strange
and they said we're a tech company if
if it makes people need to use a
computer in any way
it's serving the ecosystem and that's
all that's all that we need like as long
as they're as long as we provide
continuous demand because they're
they're ultimately a hardware company
like we were working on software stuff
but they said you know as long as our
chips are out in the world and haven't
being needed
it doesn't matter if this particular
thing turns a profit and that's kind of
like how i see the used game
it's like you keep people playing games
it
it serves the big picture and understand
this when i say it's a cancer
there's a lot of things that
in our our society it's like holy [ __ ]
did you know we used to smoke like
[ __ ] crazy
right and all of a sudden the surgeon
general had to go all right here's the
truth
this thing is actually really bad so if
you want to do it that's okay but
understand that there's an
impact you doing this and it became
incumbent upon the system to be able to
provide
a stop gap so that the consumer is
informed and understand
you still have the option to do it if
you want to but i don't think it's the
consumer's responsibility to
fix that i think it's the industry's
responsibility to go
guys this is our problem and fortunately
this is an industry of professional
problem solvers we have literally the br
the most brilliant minds that create
puzzles
as as a as a hobby and as a vocation
to go this is a big boss battle that we
have to fix
there is clearly a and especially an
economic downturn
those typically are 100 percent um
an opposite right so as as a economy
declines
it need for entertainment soars so
that's why there's more podcasts that
have
jumped up in the last four to five
months i think it's something like 750
000 new podcasts is because people are
like i need a distraction or i need
information
or i'm stuck at home and i need
something to fill up this time
and then that increases on views on the
streaming services
are up like over 100 except for mixer
which was somehow only at 0.2 which i
don't even understand
how they didn't increase at all when
everyone else did so much but i guess
that's why they're shutting down at the
end of the month bye-bye
but i'm just saying talk about it very
very clear that i'm not
faulting a um
the consumer the player the buyer
for trying to seek entertainment
in a in the most viable way for them i'm
not faulting anybody there
what i'm saying is that there's an
impact to the industry for doing that
and if you want to support games
then that may not be the best way to do
it but it's incumbent upon the
system to fix itself and not the
it's it's the monarchy to fix the the
kingdom
and not the proletariat i think that's
fair i think that is coming like i think
that's happening i think with things
like game pass but also just like
with the sales infrastructure like i
think steam obviously have been
brilliant in that for years
it's interesting seeing sony it feels
like sony are like on the playstation
i'm seeing way more sales way more
discounts
way more kind of lifetime management of
a product so like you know the game
comes out full price
then it's in this sale then it's in this
sale and obviously as a developer i see
the back end of that that we have the
conversations about how we want to
handle our
kind of tales and it does seem like that
stuff's working to an extent
i remember my my first exposure to any
of this
topic was uh
my career began with a lot of these
conversations because my first real
gig was that game company's first game
flow and that flow was
uh initially brought on as a launch
title for the playstation network
because back then you know this was the
daw the
the end of the ps2 and they were like
we've only ever done box titles ps3's
big innovation over
over xbox was like this built-in
internet
capability uh or wi-fi capability i
think it was uh
for um for uh uh
and and coupling that rather with having
an online
store that could sell these super cheap
games because that just that wasn't a
thing you know it was steam really
wasn't even a thing and because i
remember that you know
flo winning at gdc downloadable game of
the year uh
and and how even just two or three years
later how incredibly pointless that
category seems such a silly title that's
so funny
and yeah it was and because there was
this differentiation it was it was kind
of like saying
indie game of the year except i've never
understood labeling
flo flower and journey as indie when
they were completely
financed and owned by sony um
so the term indie is entirely a
marketing term
austin if you say out loud we'll all get
in trouble yeah
that's true blake twice but it was i
remember the thing was
when by the time like flow i think came
out it was like
7.99 or something like that but then
journey you know it had taken
three times longer to make you know we
had an orchestral score
it was a much more elaborate game and so
exactly in line of this they said we
think we're going to price this one at
14.99 which i think was one of the
highest prices
they had ever done for a for a
playstation network exclusive like there
was no
there was no plan at the time to do a
box version they did they did later but
it wasn't initially in the cards at all
and so 1499 was represented like because
people the perception was what
14.99 for just data like i don't get
a book and a box and a thing to put on
my shelf like a file
is not worth 14.99 and i remember this
especially showing up because they said
we're really excited to release a
soundtrack album um but in those days
default position was itunes is 9.99 an
album but they said
we can't price an album at three
quarters the cost of the game that it's
for
uh we have to or more than that yeah
about 75 so they said we're gonna do the
album at 499 and i was like i've never
even heard of an album being that cheap
you know the streaming services didn't
even exist and then the hilarious thing
was that
both both ended up doing gangbusters
numbers
and it was like and then right after
that i got hired to do a mobile game
that was aspiring to be the
the first stab at like premium content
like a triple a
quote but made for ios and we it was a
really elaborate production they lost
their shirts on it sadly because
they it was the same they were like
we're gonna charge 9.99 for an ios game
and it was like people were telling them
you're insane
you're absolutely insane and still to
this day
i think people will look at that and go
that's outrageously expensive for a
mobile game and i'm like this was a team
of
50 people that spent years on this game
and it's
in unreal and it looked like it could go
toe-to-toe with anything
um but just that perception you know
that that and i don't have any answers
to that you know it's one of those where
i i go i don't know it you know i always
come back to the cliche of
you know if you go to starbucks twice in
a week you've already spent more money
than that on something that you got 20
minutes of value after you know 20
minutes so it's like yeah that's
a lot of big-ass coffee that's true this
one's been empty since
the first five minutes i've still got
plenty left
uh i don't know i imagine that all of
you have worked on games that have been
at the start of
a new console generation at some point
um because my question originally mike
was like is anything
is there something specific about
working with a new
hardware platform that is going to make
this ten dollars more expensive so i
guess
is there any insight any of you can
offer to how difficult it is to make
something
at the start of a new generation because
like i know that there are often devs
who come out and i think
the this the the wii u was surprisingly
easy to develop for if i remember
correctly it was either that or really
hard it was one of the two and it was
like that's really interesting
they always find it interesting which of
the platforms is supposed to be easy and
which is difficult but
new hardware is obviously a whole other
thing yeah i mean it got easier because
back in the day they were all like
completely bespoke
and often like parts of them were
written in
in the case of nintendo and sony like in
japanese so it was like
you genuinely like going from ps1 to ps2
to ps3 they were completely different
devices and it was just
always a massive shift to the system
especially if you were a company
you know i mean i'm lucky that i use
unity and unreal and ut unreal have
massive access and do whatever they want
et cetera et cetera like
i i get i relatively safe from
generation to generation
but if you're using your own like
proprietary engine you have to rebuild
that at least you used to
nowadays it's better in that basically
all the consoles are just pcs
like fundamentally there are pcs there
is you know there's a lot of
um of essentially stuff you have to plug
into i'm trying to think of yeah
straightforward words for it but like
you have to plug into whatever the os
is whatever their platform is but it's
much much more straightforward so that's
helpful
but it is it is tricky i had it with i
did a launch title for um
uh google did a vr headset called the
daydream
uh which i think lasted for about nine
months yeah no it's fair enough
um we did a launch title for it and i
like
literally i think like a month before
launch i was flying out to san francisco
to fiddle with essentially like because
they were still figuring out all of the
software and firmware for the system
and i was literally like in google's
offices interestingly
uh their offices are a level in watch
dogs too which was
weird when i played watch dogs too
because i was like i've been here um i
looked for the ign office because we're
really close to
uh oh you were the ubisoft office and
they didn't put it in he's like oh
that's kind of that's that's that's an
intentional slide i feel like yeah
i was gonna say that would have been an
interesting uh kind of
controversy they should have made like a
bad media company it would have been
funny
they had a meme that was the thing so
the google office
there's a couple of different google
campuses and obviously there's all the
stuff in watchdogs too where they go to
the big google campus
but the the the google office that i was
in uh when i was doing that stuff
it is like the location of in the story
like there's an evil corporation
building like home security it's like a
it's like a
it's like a home security management
system and you go into their campus
and it's just this and if you don't know
it's google like it's just a
non-descript campus but it's definitely
it's
and and the interiors are right so like
someone
who worked on that went to the google
campus i was anyway
took photos presumably i'm pretty
it was weirdly well produced anyway but
that's my point is like so yeah there's
a lot of additional r d essentially with
a with a console jump
especially to the companies that aren't
using unreal or unity so
you're you're first party obviously
that's i mean there's lots of r d just
in general
um with the with the triple a develop
triple a studios they usually have their
own kind of internal engine
uh again they're gonna have to rebuild
all of that from scratch the platforms
are good like they do
like tell you information beforehand you
know um you'll
you'll get invited into sony's offices
and get like a five-hour demonstration
of like everything and how everything's
he doesn't give it to the likes of me um
but but they'll walk the devs through
and they'll kind of
they'll give you that kind of awareness
of what's coming up and what the
features are so you can kind of
tailor your game to it but yeah if
you're building anything new it's gonna
be hard i don't think that necessarily
justifies a price jump because
obviously as a business you're looking
at new platforms and you're weighing up
like
yes it will cost us more r d yes it's
more risky but you know there's not
going to be many games
at launch and we know it's going to have
a big marketing push so actually it's
worth that extra cost i don't think it's
like a one to one kind of
this is ten dollars more work per unit
but
i think what's more if you if you want
to make the case that game development
is more expensive that does work but
that's more to do with just long term
people want more pixels people want
higher frame rates people want more
assets on screen
bigger worlds more story you know more
polis like all of those things cost
money to produce
um but but i've never liked that as an
excuse for price hikes because i think
bluntly the most profitable games right
now are free to play games so i know
that was basically the hypothesis i was
trying to get to was that
i don't buy that this is no no
not that i don't buy that this has
happened for the
the justification that the public they i
think they
assume that they are going to assume is
well if we do it for next gen they're
just going to think it's better it's
more expensive it's like a higher
quality product but i don't
imagine it is tangibly ten dollars more
expensive a unit for them to actually
make that port
um but i wasn't positive either uh sorry
troy i think i cut you off oh no
i was just gonna say i thought mike said
he wants more asses on the screen and i
was like
yeah hey that's it play ghostbusters
that's a very my thing i'll say and yeah
until the empire goes
live it's not a qualitative statement
that doesn't tell us if there's a lot of
no it didn't say it was related to us
just said play it um yeah
it's the ign headline tomorrow we always
have to have one per episode right
there i can tell you that the ratings
leaked that anyway you do see man ass
quite frequently john wick
creator says he wants more asses in
games
that's what the hell i like how he's now
the john wick creator
chad would not like that move aside chad
yeah john wick
hex john wick john [ __ ] wick
john that was your line that was your
line i got to say your line the first
[ __ ] line
john [ __ ] wick i was like
uh to get back to value um i think
that's a really interesting thing that
comes up when it comes to
um game reviews specifically as well
and this is a conversation that i feel
like i have with people a lot is uh and
we may have discussed this on the
podcast before
is how subjective value actually is so a
lot of people will say well like why
don't you just say
buy it at this rate um don't buy it at
this rate and every single time i'm
always like i don't know you
i don't know how much you think five
dollars is
um value's so subjective that it's
almost a useless qualifier and that you
can't do the buy this now thing because
i don't
know what your finances are uh i think i
i might have spoken about this last week
like i'll spend
a thousand dollars on a batman statue
but you try to get me to buy a
dress over a hundred dollars and i'm
like what
a pair you buy me a batman statue for a
thousand dollars i'd love that
well i'm probably not going to do that
have you ever heard me i i love that
you're saying that value is subjective
have you ever
heard me say the phrase uh know your
worth and [ __ ] your value
i haven't let me think ever i need to
know what that means
so very very briefly i was talking to a
friend of mine and she was talking about
how hard it is to date
and i said she was like you just you
just don't understand like
what it takes to to show your value um
to to people that you're trying to date
i was like well you need to know your
worth and [ __ ] your value
because like if you look at gold gold
its value depending upon the stock
market depending upon economy depending
upon if where it wore or not whatever
the price of gold is just constantly
doing this looks like an ekg
but it's worth its true worth is found
that there is
no other element in the entire universe
that
is better at harnessing and conducting
electricity than gold
and that is its inherent worth in
so value its perception of what its
cost is and what it what it should cost
to have
some of it is constantly in fluctuation
but its worth is literally eternalness
the fact that that thing was blown out
by a [ __ ] star
eons ago um so that's why i always say
you need to know your worth and [ __ ]
your value your worth is what's internal
and inherent
your value is external and doesn't
[ __ ] matter
well yeah because value depends on what
other people think of something right
i don't know how to relate that to video
games but it's very beautiful
thank you this has just been a quick
deep thoughts with
what is the inherent worth of games i
could make this relevant watch this [ __ ]
utterly subjective though right like
that's my goal
look at that troy's exiting i don't know
what's happening just watching audio
or live things you know you got quiet
just suddenly yeah i it's for me too
mike is also noticeably
critiquing my feedback and thoughts yeah
zoom might just be being a dick to us
it's because like this guy talks a lot i
can control everybody's volume i just
want to let you guys know that
[Laughter]
is that why austin's basically mute that
would that would that would track
i i believe that completely austin have
you worked on any games that
were uh at the top of a new console
generation cycle
yeah well and and pathless is is a ps5
launch title
um and um but other yeah i mean
obviously um even back to the very
beginning of my career
with flow as a ps3 launch title um
that that uh i can tell you for music
it has never impacted the cost as far as
i'm aware
um uh like the the the the fact that
it's
shifting to a new generation because the
bones of what's possible musically has
been relatively consistent for
a long time i mean since since like the
late 90s basically
it's it's it's more and better versions
of the same basic bag of tricks
so it's like if you can afford to hire
an orchestra for your score
it's not like somehow implementing those
recordings is
going up in cost because of the new
hardware a ps5
offers you versus a ps4 that kind of
thing if anything
um that stuff is reducing your cost
because just more power more efficiency
you know less hacky workarounds uh
generally speaking as you move forward
but that that mostly falls on the
software side you know it's as
tools like unreal and wise and fmod get
better
those are helping to reduce your costs
but
as games get longer larger
and more cinematic or just bigger in
scope
does that not directly impact how much
music like
before you're like we can have like a
theme and that's it or you can only do
midi like we've seen that increase
like you said from the 90s but i would
think you're like oh
we were going to only do 20 minutes of
music now we need 200 minutes of music
because it's just wall-to-wall
i actually have had that happen before
um
i feel like i probably shouldn't say
what yeah
but uh do it but i've definitely had one
dude these enablers um i yeah i did have
one where i had to go back to them and
say
give me more money yeah i i did i hated
doing it because it goes against
my nature to say like i signed on the
agreement which came
like my signature had the promise to
deliver
sink or swim and i because i understand
that
games are hard to make you know
sometimes scope gets out of control
sometimes you know a key member of the
team has to leave for personal reasons
and blah blah there's a million things
that can really
challenge the development of a game and
i don't like to be the guy that says
well you know
look i know that you've had to add six
months to your schedule because of
things out of your control or just
because you're dedicated to making this
as good as it can be
but you know i signed here i'm supposed
to be out by this state so
i you know i mean it takes a lot i go in
knowing that the road might be a little
rocky and that's okay
and so it was it was a very emotionally
daunting i waffled on this for months
because i was looking and i was going
i'm on track for this score to be 300
what i
signed on to do um and
i've spent all the money i'm making
nothing um i've spent all the money on
the production costs and even with that
i still need more
to be able to just deliver what i think
the game needs because the game's scope
it's such a better game like this was
one where the scope increase
absolutely was justified um and
and they weren't mismanaging it wasn't a
scope increase because they couldn't
keep their process under control or
things like that
they just found through iteration a
better version that happened to be
substantially larger than the original
and so yeah that was one where but
that's again
just to to alana's specific question
i wouldn't chalk that kind of thing up
to a console
evolution that's not that has nothing to
do with the
hardware it's just game development
really so
but that's the only time i've ever had
that happen i did there was another game
i did i will say this one absolver
where i did deliver uh about twice as
much music as i was
contracted to um but um but that was it
was the same and that was one i didn't
ask for anything
additional on that one you know they
were they were they treated me well and
it was devolver was the publisher and i
liked working with them in the
company it was their first time making a
game it was their debut title as a
studio french developer
uh that i just adored working with
everything about that experience was
really positive so i was like
don't don't sweat it like i'm not i
wouldn't have even brought it up
you know it was just on the flip just as
a little a little anecdote tangent
i did have this once happen i feel like
this is another one i should probably
not say who it was
but this was a publisher that um is a
very deep
pocketed publisher and and and this was
one where
i was the contract actually said if you
we tr
there was an extensive period of
negotiation up front to try to figure
out how much music the game was gonna
need
and they had a pretty good sense of what
their scope was but it was so huge
that it was like it could it could it
could vary by if a five percent change
would would mean many many many hours
worth because it's just it was one of
these that
swung but with a wide you know a wide
berth and so they um they said um
uh we have a a per second
of music uh rate uh above the contract
uh that we want to uh hold you to um
and uh i have no idea what's going on
there i'm fiddling i'm sorry i'm
i'm annoying so sorry you're so
you're so he hasn't spoken
i'm a fiddler i'm over here like i'm
like a little fiddle i'm fiddling and i
i fiddled and i had to take off the
wrapper from my
i'm sorry austin i will i will yield my
to the chairman no well the end of the
story is
simply that this was one where they they
said um
uh you know any amount over the
contracted amount
uh even if it's justifiable by scope
increase is going to come with a price
tag
that we hold each other to like they
were doing as much to protect me as to
protect themselves to say
you know scope increase has to come with
a very
quantifiable price tag so that we
feel that and it was the only time i've
ever seen it that it was literally
quantified down to the second
of music it's really interesting to me
austin how
different your operations are in terms
of like the flexibility that you've
spoken about just on this show compared
to something like sag-aftra
where they can't really like i imagine
troy i imagine you're sag i feel like
you aren't
allowed to be flexible i'm like well
i'll do this part for free
and we'll charge slightly more for this
like you seem to work with them
extremely flexibly are there no like
union rules that say
for every hour you must get paid this
much because you seem to have a
different approach to
pricing with every single game that you
work on is it about me or austin
austin i imagine troy for you because
you'd be sad it would be the same right
still no no there are sag craz created
minimums but they don't create maximums
and they don't say you can do whatever
you want
so and i believe this to be true of
everybody it's your business like it's
it's i'm in the business of
me right i'm not in the business of
anybody else so
it is up to me and and the one the first
sets that i was ever on i
may have shared this story before lou
diamond phillips will always get credit
for saying this
i asked him is like at what point in
your crew go stop
i was like i haven't asked the question
he's like you're already wrong because
what i hear is someone saying at what
point will i arrive and you never will
if you believe in something you ask for
it from the jump
and so like if i if if i'm on a project
or whatever
i can ask them questions but i'm not
hired yet so
i can sign an nda all all day long
but at the end of the day i'm not an
employee i will
i will never be an employee of that
company and
that's something that i had to i can be
as part of as much of a part of the team
as i can in any any studio that opens
their doors to me and go
let's here's the here's the factor and
here's how we make the sausage come in
and we're going to trust you with our
secrets we're going to trust you with
our secrets we're going to trust you
with our
the way our processes we're going to
trust you with our budget we're going to
trust you with all this information
because we want you to feel like you're
a part of the team so that hopefully you
care more
and so your performance reflects that so
if they bring me in
and they go here's this game and
and here's the projected scope of what
it's going to be we go okay
for me to do what i do on this scope of
a game for this amount of time that it's
going to take
this is what that is worth that's the
value of this
and we either agree or disagree so if i
come to mike and i go how much do you
need
from me what do you need me to do he's
like yo i need this much
but i have this much to be able to pay
for it i go cool that's great
that's not sag setting that that is a
relationship and a conversation between
either myself or my agent and typically
my agent and i will come together and
like
what do you think i was like dude i'm
going to be working on this for
x amount of time and i really want to be
a part of this project
or it's a super super small product
there was one that
i it was it was a a game that ended up
getting canceled
and i hope that the team is okay as far
as i know they're still
up and running and they just publisher
came through and they went
nope to like 60 of the projects that
were coming across the board
and i took the project not because of
the money
uh nor because of the cachet of the
title but had everything to do with
those like i've always wanted to play
this kind of character
and this person said no audition here
this we will give you this and i went
that's great and
my agent was like we should be asking
for this much money it's a lead
character and i was like i don't care
i i will go make that money somewhere
else i really just want to be a part of
that
sag has nothing to do with that they
don't sag only plays into it as far as
minimums when it comes to if you want to
do this this is the
bare minimum that you must pay and with
that austin i feel like
but you don't have no i yeah well it
depends on if it's a union title or not
right
well i'll let me answer that in a second
but just it's just to clarify something
you're saying troy
there are minimums which means that if i
was making a game and i said
you know there is nothing no one's
taking anything up front we're all just
going to revenue share on the end and
it's just
four of us you know what sag would
actually not let you do that right you
can't actually
do things for free there you must do a
per session minimum
you can do a deferred thing so i can if
i wanted to prefer okay
i can make up a thing and they say you
have to pay
um a minimum of this but you can do a
deferment
up to a certain amount and we've done
stuff like that before it's where it's
like i'm going to do this work
and i'm going to get something on the
back end you know that's that is that is
a possible thing to do
i don't think it should be an industry
standard because not everybody is
friends not everybody has the
relationships
that i've worked really [ __ ] hard to
have if this is your first gig
what value does my relationship have
with mike biffle it's like
it's that those are those are born out
of relationships
right there's like there's a definition
an inherent word well
honestly what traces our relationships
you are talking about about worth like
it is
uh a case-by-case basis i guess and it's
part of
that concern yeah and to directly answer
that alana the
for me it absolutely every single
project
we conceive of the agreement uh
completely from scratch
and try to make it very very very
specific to what their needs are even if
it's my fifth time working with somebody
and we have a long history and there's a
there's a there's a kind of trajectory
that you can map
uh to the to our prior agreements we'll
still try to mostly take this one in a
vacuum because i've worked with people
where
they had a really nice budget on one day
and then the next day was a passion
project right and no one was making
anything and i'm not gonna go to them
and say well you know the president says
it's this
right and so yeah to me it's it's
exactly troy's point and then just on a
technical note there is no such thing as
a composer's union
it's actually illegal in the united
states for composers to unionize
because we were ruled in federal court
not at the supreme court level but there
have been many attempts to
to to appeal this to the supreme court
it's never made it
we are considered much closer to
employers than employees
and so we cannot unionize uh because you
hired musicians you've got the orchestra
because we hire people
we're in this middle ground where we are
hired and then we subcontract musicians
recording engineers whatever and they
said
you you do enough hiring that you're
you can't form a you're management
you're not labor yeah that's exactly
super interesting and so wow
to bring this whole conversation like
into a bubble that
me asking the two of you those questions
of like how flexible is whatever you
charge and it seems like the answer is
extremely flexible
um that does circle back to should games
be seventy dollars the answer has to be
absolutely no uh it is an arbitrary
and in some cases yes but it is an
arbitrary number that's sort of pulled
out of the sky to be like
can we get this amount of money because
every single game
costs such a completely different
amount of money you guys charge
completely different amounts of money so
does everyone else i feel like
there is definitely no rule and this is
obvious to the three of you but
for the purposes of uh people in the
audience who maybe don't understand the
price points there's certainly no rule
that means game should be 60
this game should be 70 dollars can i
jump in you can
jump in on one thing you said they're
just saying it's contextually
interesting
the the three of us are all obviously
kind of we've got reputations we've got
access we've got you know networking all
this stuff
we are often able to change our prices
and stuff like that because the
project's interesting because we're
bluntly able to financially because
people will pay us
there are a lot of kind of salaried
individuals in the games industry
who don't have that luxury who are very
much locked in from at all levels right
like from like
people who are working minimum wage
obviously if you think about this
industry in larger terms like everyone
who's working in gamestop right but like
all the way through qa who are often
incredibly badly treated
there's a whole range of salaries and a
whole range of dependencies and
and these conversations often i worry we
can we can
forget that and and that does mean there
is a baseline for games and if you're
making triple a games
you are looking at like certain
baselines in terms of per person per
year there are numbers that are more
solid
i'd say well do you think that they uh
point one is i totally recognize the
only way i was even able to get into the
industry was that i had the privilege of
living at home with the family who was
very supportive of me making no money
because my first two years i didn't make
any money i was writing for free
and i would borrow money from my parents
to fly to events or whatever to
be able to cover games and then pay them
back when i could from my
my shitty casual job so i would not have
been able to do that
at all uh if i didn't have the enormous
privilege of having a very supportive
family who are willing to help me
financially it's just
it just wouldn't have been possible and
i feel like i i try to speak about that
as much as i can things are not
necessarily impossible for everyone
i could not have done that without help
um
but the second point do you think that
that means that
where a studio is concerned they oh no
they do i already know the answer to
this they look at
at the amount of people they're
employing and what all their salaries
are and then they look at how much money
they need to make but i don't feel like
that buys into the 60
thing when every single one across the
board is 60 every single game is 60
dollars
regardless oh no it's defined by the
market yeah for sure it's it's defined
by the market i think if the audience
if the audience tomorrow decided to stop
spending 60 dollars on
aaa games they'd be 50 the week after
you know it's it is
it is always going to be defined by the
market they think that they can get away
with 70
and they're probably right in the same
way as within these we actually this is
happening slightly in the indie space
like
we're definitely getting a bit bolder
with our pricing on the indie side as
well like you can see
if you look at like your median kind of
indie games
yes there's lots of stuff that's
incredibly cheap but if you look at kind
of
i guess the prestige indie games you're
gonna see
you're seeing those numbers creep up a
little bit and they didn't they were
they were trending down for a long time
it does feel like maybe we as an
industry across the board from indie
triple a
feel that the audience is willing to pay
a bit more and
ultimately whether or not we're right on
that we'll define whether we are
business
i think um these calibrations are always
gonna happen what's interesting about
the console shift is it
it is this watermark which they will use
to try a new pricing structure
and maybe it'll recalibrate you know to
back down again but ultimately yeah they
will charge what you will pay that is
fundamentally how i mean i guess
capitalism right but that's why
that's why i think that it's the reverse
of what you were suggesting alana where
you were saying
it you know we look at our costs and
then say therefore the game must
therefore we must charge this much i
think it i think it more often works the
other way around
where they will say this is the most
number of people we can hire and the
most amount of time we can spend because
we know we will invariably be charging
60
and if we sell this many units you know
that's why you won't
go rush out and hire 250 people
for a project just without having any
sense of
like you would never make a decision
like that kind of blindly because
you you'll never recoup that call you'll
never even make it to the finish line
like so i think it's
the budgeting that's being driven by the
inevitable price point and not the other
way around does that mean when you're
pitching a video game which i believe
maybe you've all been a part of that
process maybe uh
that mike is the only heart you have an
idea of how many units you will sell at
the pitching
i've always seen that in the pitch decks
where they look at comparable titles and
they say
you know here's a game that's kind of
like our game it's like real
it's like realtors when they're they
always drive around the neighborhood and
see
how much this house down the street
charged and it had similar amount of
renovation done at a similar amount of
time and you try to build
a catalog of similar i mean why am i
answering this mike you're the guy to be
talking about
i just like that we all smirked because
we all remembered the exact same story
that we can't say on the show
but yeah the um the no it starts with
that like
genuinely most conversations you'll have
yes obviously you want to show your
passion for the genre and some cool art
and whatever
but no the question most publishers most
want you to answer is
how much does it cost to the player and
how many units do you think
realistically you'll sell
because ultimately those numbers have to
it's simple multiplication those have to
cover the cost of production
and they will argue with you on both the
reason they want to know price as well
is that price does define content in
terms of the player's expectation
i mean there will inevitably be people
who i think everyone in
everyone watching this will have a sense
of what a 20 indie game should have in
it
and what that vibe is um what ten dollar
what if
what a what a triple a game triple a is
weird and
it has all coalesced around this one
price point but if i said to you
starting tomorrow some aaa games are
going to be uh 100
and some aaa games going to be 40
dollars that the audi
the audience would be able to decide
which ones felt right at those different
price points right
they would have a an inherent sense of
where that should land
and publishers are the same publishers
know and i've had conversations i think
i brought this up on a
couple of shows ago but like i've had
conversations where they've been we like
this as a 20
game but could you could you take it to
a 60 game and they're not talking about
just what price they're gonna stick on
it they're talking about
scale of content theme whatever
will it have multiplayer you know those
kind of decisions um
but yeah and it's and you know it's
always speculation and when especially
when you're looking at like sales
numbers
often that's very optimistic and you
don't necessarily know where that's
going to land
um but on the publisher's side they're
going to go away with those numbers and
they hire they have
analysts they have people this doesn't
have my accent they're not guessing they
will go away
and they'll do the numbers and the
statistical analysis and they'll go
we think this game will sell exactly
this number of units
and that will be a number that the
publisher knows internally they don't
usually share it with you because
obviously
that's a that's a useful proprietary
piece of information for them and if
you're making your game and you're like
we need six months more
you go back to them and say can we can
we get some more money and keep going
for six months and release it later
they're gonna look back at that number
and they're gonna go start worth six
months no
or yes it's worth six months and they're
within their rights to do that right but
that also is again speaks to preset
pre-orders
because they're like you know what um
we weren't sure the last of us is a
perfect example
sony had no idea they had
all of this data and evidence to point
to the fact that because it was naughty
dog based upon all of uncharted success
this is probably what it was going to do
but they still it was a gamble and they
had to pitch and pitch and pitch
to sony to get that great game green lit
not they weren't just like because we're
not enough we're gonna make whatever we
want they're like
you make uncharted like you're doing a
brand new ip that is completely out of
your sphere and you want us to put how
many dollars into it
and then all of a sudden that trailer
comes out and they're like okay now yeah
you can slip
we actually if if you'll just you finish
the game and we understand that you guys
need more time
so we're going to give you this much
time so i mean that's
that and that was based upon the the
audience response
and how many pre-orders that game got
they were like this is this game's gonna
do better than we think it's gonna do
but it that's that's not a guaranteed
thing and that's with naughty dog
you take a studio that could be their
first thing
or it could be like we're a smaller
studio and we've kind of done this
i i always bring up the example of eli
roth with cabin fever
and cabin fever he did for like
dude 250 grand i think he did that thing
on a bootstrap shoestring budget
but the profitability of that movie was
so great that they were like all right
we're going to give you a big thing and
that's how we got to do hostile
so the jump in that it was like you've
proven yourself here
with your five talents or 10 talents now
we're gonna give you a hundred talents
it's it's that kind of
sometimes you need that not just budget
but you need the profitability and a lot
of times that perception and that
the game that you can make is voted on
by
people and their wallets and them doing
that in faith
i remember when journey came out most
people
obviously it was very well received and
to your naughty dog example no one had
any clue how well it was going to be
received because we just thought you
know this could easily be
mass maligned as pretentious garbage
um and um and and literally until the
day of release i had no idea what to
expect and
but i do remember that there was always
probably still to this day
a subset of players that would go 15
bucks
for 90 minutes of gameplay like who do
you think i am
you know like like they really thought
that was bad that was a bit like that
they thought this game is so overpriced
for how short it is and then you would
invariably see like if that was on a
youtube comment there'd be an
invariably these replies saying why does
grinding for gear or stats
automatically make that time more about
this is 90 minutes anyone in that
conversation is wrong right
everyone's arguing from their own
perspective it's interesting
absolutely that's why this is hard
because because we know that different
people will have different opinions
there will be people who are like
i never buy a game at launch i'm really
smart i wait six months and i get it
you're a very discretionary buyer well
and a lot of like brought this up a lot
like there's always going to be a bunch
of these people who buy everything
immediately it's it's
they're not wrong they're just we have
to predict them and and make games that
are within their means to kind of
absolutely and i have a lot of sympathy
for the argument that alana's brought up
multiple times of you know if you're
someone who buys
three or four games per year um
the notion of getting a lot of content
out of that is something that you're
really like
like i saw people complaining about the
last of us part two for the lack of
multiplayer
and i'm like when does it ever enter
into your mind
to playing a game like that that i wish
i was online shooting at my friends
right now like
uh the multiplayer for the first one was
really good it was really really good
and i know a lot of people that can
that's
it continued to to keep that game in
their drive
uh i don't doubt it i am not that player
though
generally i get i get your points i i i
want a multiplayer version of that but i
do want an open world version to where
it's just like
side quest missions or whatever apps are
[ __ ] lutely i want to be in that
world more
and i spent 30 hours in it like but that
that
that notion of like i get to buy three
or two i get a birthday and a christmas
and that's it i i 100 understand that
so if if i as a as a parent or like all
right tell you what
100 bucks i save 20 bucks a year or
potentially more
40 bucks a year if i pay 100 bucks i
give you a pass
and you get to play everything you want
dude i get that
i just me being being able to see at
least the matrix that i can see i look
at the developer and they go
oh [ __ ] we can't we can't make
every game to where it's just gonna be
like amortized over how many studios
that publisher has
you know what i mean how many game
passes are sold like if everybody did
that it was like that's what spotify
does
so netflix which to that point
everybody used to make their money off
of album sales
that's how you made your money and then
rolling stone did this great article
they were like the top grossing
um artists of of the decade or whatever
it was
and it was you two dave matthews band um
rolling stones there was like a few that
were like okay of course
and it had nothing to do with their
album sales and had everything to do
with the fact that you two
for the 40 years has always been on tour
always and their tours are massive and
they make
dave matthews constantly touring and
it's because they make their money on
the road
now since covet and there ain't no music
festivals and there ain't no club shows
dude i have no idea how
the typical indie artist is gonna make
money because they're not gonna do
enough of album sales
and so to future proof this industry to
be able to understand and go
that that game pass may not be it may
result in fewer studios and fewer games
but a better value to the player i
understand that but i don't think it's
this like magic wand now we just make
all games the same price or
we get every game for this because if
we've seen every
anything look at how many stations that
we used to have and how many offerings
there used to be
and now it's pretty much just kind of
down to like five
we either do netflix hulu or whatever
the [ __ ] hbo max is or quibby
which needs to just stop um is quivi
still around does that die
no it's around still though wow
the chad is currently talking about the
idea that who's chad
if a game is like 15 to 20 hours then it
should be a certain price or if it's
shorter it should be a certain price i
think we spoke about that last week if
you guys want to
check that out but um the idea that
certain hour value should equal certain
price
doesn't really work because the length
of the game isn't necessarily related to
how much it cost
to make um so a game can be a hundred
hours but costs the same amount as
a game with very different features
that's only 20 hours long so that
doesn't
quite translate that way also different
people value time differently right like
true i love a game that i hear is 20
hours if it's a hundred
thousand nice also also just to that to
that point mic of different people value
to different time differently
also games are all made all over the
world where people are salaried
very differently and so if you have a
story it's made
in you know a country with a very
different cost of living situation
that they could potentially make a far
larger game for a certain point
price point than a u.s counterpart could
hope to do it is interesting though on
the flip side of that um
i pay attention to like investor calls
and presentations that any of the major
publishers do
and activision i feel like i bring this
up more often than i should but i found
it so fascinating
activision specifically um where i guess
activision blizzard
had a particular presentation i think
two years ago about
the amount of hours that someone uh or
the amount of money that someone spends
on a movie per
hour is always the same like you're
guaranteed to be getting
15 whatever a movie ticket uh and it
it's nowhere near the length and so the
kind of thesis was that it was unfair
that you would pay 60 for call of duty
but you could
uh play it for 200 hours and that means
that the
um perceived value of the film industry
is somehow higher than the perceived
value
of video games because of the hours
spent actually in those things so it's
like they say the opposite where even if
it's a multiplayer game where in theory
it's the same maps over and over again
they aren't necessarily constantly
iterating on that there aren't scripted
sequences with constant cutscenes that
is guiding you through that 200 hours
that you're playing that multiplayer
it's other people that are providing the
content really
um by that point but they're like if
you're in there for 200 hours and you
only played 60 bucks we got ripped off
the film industry's not getting ripped
off it's like such a such an interesting
thing to read
activision blizzard actually write that
out and compare themselves to like the
epoxy that's such an apples and oranges
though because
he was one that made this argument as
well he was like how much money is like
if i do the cost analysis versus an hour
and a half for 15 bucks or 20 bucks
versus 60 bucks for 200 hours he was
like
they cost pennies but it's the the thing
is is that it's still
it's still the investment however much i
use it
look at the completionist rate right
there's people that paid 60 bucks for a
game
that paid played 30 40 percent they got
fatigued from it or they'd walked away
from it or it wasn't what they wanted to
do
so that isn't like like someone who
walks out of a movie theater is gonna be
like my money back
and the manager's gonna go you sat in
there for 45 minutes
you knew it was gonna be bad you know if
they're like hey the projector broke or
there was a problem here i was like we
understand and we'll do that
i'm using some anachronistic analogies
right now that people are like
what is this
oh this podcast is not going to age well
and then my eight track broke and my
pinto
oh [ __ ] no but but but you're but that
also
raises the point that one of the
challenges of the movie industry has
always been that
that if i if i recall anti-trust
legislation says that the movie studios
cannot own the movie theaters
and so there's always been a a little
bit of a challenge where the theaters to
survive have to charge a certain amount
and that and
and remarkably little of that it carries
over to the
the movie studio that's that's actually
the massive in games as well
what do you mean and no one knows this
so i remember my first day
in industry um my my first job they had
like this kind of induction process and
training where basically they just
introduced you to them it was basically
oils and smokes yeah it's
specifically though it was like it was
basically like an introduction to the
business of the industry which they used
to kind of because they knew they were
hiring a lot of young people who were
gamers but maybe didn't understand
business
or how the games business worked
obviously people are much more informed
now than they were
when i started but one of the things i
will always remember this is they had a
slide where they put up the box sort of
one of their games
and it said next to it sixty dollars and
then it had the bar
chart and the percentages basically like
pie chart of who that sixty dollars goes
to
right it's like well you know you've got
the distribution
you've got the store you've got the
salary of the person who sells it at the
till
you've got the platform holder platform
holder makes money from every game sold
on their platform you know every
playstation game like five bucks
whatever it was five to seven bucks
it's something like there's like a
licensing thing and also they control
the
printing in a lot of cases i don't know
if that's still true it was true before
um basically it works out on a 60
game if i remember right this was years
ago basically and then obviously sorry
the publisher not the developer and then
to the developer i think a 60 game used
to be about five to ten dollars to the
developer of that game
and that's fascinating what's also
interesting is
that's somewhat true on if you buy it on
online if you buy on amazon
you're still paying for you know amazon
obviously you're taking a big chunk of
that
but a different chunk if you buy online
the money works differently because if
you buy
as a digital copy i mean a digital copy
of that game just cuts out a bunch of
middlemen
so you're in a weird position where
probably i make more money
from selling a 10 indie game
on steam the naughty dog if they were
independent i guess would make from last
of us
per copy which is weird right and that's
where these
economics it's like an extra layer of
craziness that kind of really messes
with the all of these expectations
it actually means that and that's why
obviously every every uh game company is
trying to get you to buy your games
digitally rather than physically
not just to avoid um uh secondhand
sales it's more because they are cutting
out so many middlemen in that process
that that sixty dollars you're paying
for a game you're buying through
playstation network
is putting a lot more money in the
pockets of the publisher and the
developer
than the version you're buying at
gamestop and that's another aspect of
this that
you basically there are so many layers
of this stuff that ultimately the number
is so vacuous and weird and i think is
it true that
also i remember once having a
conversation with someone i assume this
was at sony but i can't remember
talking about the economics of console
exclusives versus those that
aren't because you raise a really good
point mike about
the like sony will make money off of
everything you buy from the playstation
store whether it's an exclusive or not
and therefore when they're figuring out
what the budgets and the pricings
would be for a console exclusive
there's actually less pressure for those
games to be profitable
as you might think because if they
encourage sale of
the console that means then i'll go buy
assassin's creed on a ps4
or ps5 because that's where that's my
console now
and and those games can actually help
keep it going
much more effectively the the role of a
game like the last of us or an uncharted
or even a journey or whatever
is to just keep you invested in the
console
yeah uh and that the rest are actually
what are paying and get you buying ps
plus
as well yeah like i don't know which is
the other thing it's much more valuable
to me as a platform holder to get you
onto a subscription
than it is to sell you a game that's why
you can see that with xbox with all of
their is i'm around saying all of their
first party stuff is in game boss
is that right like i think it is now
yeah
they are now launching all of them on
game pass because selling you a game for
60 dollars they get 60
they never see you again that's why
they're awesome subscribe
they just want you to subscribe to game
pass which is also on pc but hasn't that
always been kind of the thing like
sony has always been hardware and
microsoft's always been software like
it's
it's or or is it the other way around to
where it's like
because if that's true that would be a
big shift for microsoft people like
we'll give away our software but like
sony's always been hardware driven
um i feel like they shift a lot
depending on who's in charge honestly i
don't feel like there are that many
consistently the reality is
the reality is nowadays i think no one's
hardware driven
bluntly no the hardware is a means to
get you a
subscription that is a means to get you
to buy the things that like you're
saying they get thirty percent from it
because again
the playstation 5 you're going to buy is
going to
a chunk of that's going to go to the
store it's going to go to this so that
like sony themselves how i don't know
how it breaks down with hardware but
like they will not get them
all the money you pay for a place right
everyone feels like it's like a big cash
cage where they're just like
money no i i understand that and i think
it was i mean don't get me wrong it's a
medium-sized cash cash
[Music]
the cage exists yeah the cage exists
it's just not as much money as you think
but the uh i think it was something like
the first
playstation 3 maybe they knew that they
were going to
lose their ass on the hardware for like
the first three years
anyway it was super incredible it was
absurd
it was like maybe like a grand in
australia no
that's like yeah it wasn't like 40
dollars yeah i remember reading that
also they were losing money on the sale
of every psp
but they were building again i don't
think that the hardware is the is the
profitable part necessarily
they want to cover their costs and
probably profit to an extent but it is
more about getting you in that ecosystem
well there was interest
it's almost like endorsement deals with
musicians because like i remember
i was talking to buddy i was like i'd
love to get a deal and it was like the
easiest deal to get is drum sets i went
what he's like yeah it's the easiest
deal to get the hardest deal to get
are picks and strings because you will
use
way more picks and strings but you only
need one drum set
you only need one guitar like getting a
guitar so what seems to be the biggest
upfront investment is actually sometimes
the easiest to give away
because you're always going to need the
smaller things
that you use that big item with so i
think that it's possible like the
the hardware is the big drum set but
then
the picks and strings where we actually
make all of our money that's i mean
yeah that's why you sell that's why you
sell the hardware iteration two years
after launch because all of your chips
got cheaper to produce
so you can you can actually start to
turn the profit or turn more
i think i think the last i might be
again might be talking absolutely
nonsense but like i think the last
console that genuinely launched
with a loss was was probably ps3 i don't
think that's been
true i don't think that was true of ps4
and xbox one i believe wasn't it
they did make a medium private made some
profit on that
it's like games too right like one of
the reasons why it's so much easier to
and we talked about this as far as games
being too long or too short or whatever
is once you build those assets once
you've built that world once you've
built that franchise out you're like
it's so much more cheaper to just do a
sequel than it is to build a whole new
ip
because you'd have to build at least you
get to reuse some of this stuff right
this is the same thing with the hardware
well even if you're not even if you're
not reusing literal assets
you've already figured out mechanics
you've done a lot of the intellectual
done the work
which is automatically you've
standardized it you've also done the
marketing you've got the noise around
your car platform hopefully the fan war
like
you know i am not a franchise guy i get
to do
one and done
or i get killed
if you haven't beat shadow of war
bye-bye
[Laughter]
um we've gone way longer than normal
because it's a live episode i figured i
would just let us
let us do that because of audio issues
and all that nonsense but there was one
last thing that i created austin wintery
this week
austin it looked like you were talking
but i didn't hear anything
i said i won a great big austin wintery
this week
you did this is the biggest austin
wintery of all time
is microphone working but i wanted to
end on the question that uh
and i don't want to misquote so i'm just
going to be vague about it um
absolutely paraphrase sean layton
basically said something along the lines
of
um the industry as it is right now with
the 60
pricing model is unsustainable uh
because games have gotten so much more
expensive to make
does anyone have any hot takes on that
he's right if we keep making the same
kinds of games on the same curve
okay that's like right now that number
that he's predicating that on
is a presumption about like continued
growth of budget and
and production costs but that's
not necessarily like it's it's it's true
if we keep scaling up in the way we're
scaling up but you could
you could theoretically stop you could
theoretically go you know what
these open world games are big enough
like we'll keep iterating and improving
and doing stuff
we don't need to keep making our world
is twice the size of the first games
world well that's awesome
i think he's right in in so far as what
sony
is making while he was at sony um i
don't think that that applies to all the
games that
do have micro transactions now which is
a significant portion i think there's
also that's why a lot of things are
going games as a service
right there's a there's a much better
thing it's like if we like to make again
one game and that's what you're going to
keep in your drive for them
that's gta was that for me man that
thing did not get come out
of my drive for years because i just
continually played that thing
i played every week yeah still i'm going
to get back into that man i've missed
that game
when i have time you ever want to join
us at fun house we're playing on monday
playing on monday yeah what time i play
gta every week
i'm busy
[Laughter]
i can tell you that that from the music
side
it is so all over the place um even just
within my career but i think especially
if you then add in all the other
composers careers
that that um there's no there's
basically
no givens even in terms of fixed costs
because there's so many different ways
to approach it you can do everything
with a computer you can do
nothing with the computer you can like
you can
you know do the whole thing by just you
know
pounding your hands on your desk and
recording it and then you're done and
record it with a cell phone that you
borrowed from someone else
like there's just literally there's no
floor
um and uh but to mike's point of you
know
there's also like you
you could theoretically just keep
getting larger and larger orchestras but
you're also like but
but why right uh you know and there's
also so many different structures that
are theoretically possible to a deal
even though in the
aaa space it tends to be a certain kind
of work for hire contract where you kind
of give all rights
away and theoretically they compensate
in exchange for that
um uh there's still nonetheless a
million different
deal structures i mean i've worked on
get like the amount of money that we
spent on the recording sessions for the
banner saga
for example because of the way we
structured that deal these were large
orchestral recordings
we spent more money on those scores than
on games with substantially higher
budgets because of the way we moved
numbers around in order to achieve that
um and so it's like
we started telling players that money
equaled quality we started we and we
brought this on ourselves like it's a
classic tech industry mistake of that we
basically said
buy the next console because it's more
better the numbers are bigger
uh this game costs twice like we
literally have been using
this game is really expensive as a
marketing like sales line for years we
we built that expectation
we told audiences that if they want
bigger better games they're going to be
more expensive
so that's on us ultimately like movies
don't do that movies
there's you you have kind of some kind
of
buzz around movie budgets but i don't
know what the budget for like
you know an avengers movie is i don't
know what the that's not being used as a
sales technique like we like to see that
value on the screen you're saying yeah
the only time i can remember that we
care what it is but like
it doesn't like i would i can imagine
players
probably would say well they should keep
spending big budgets they should keep
making games bigger and better
but that's a very game specific thing
we've we've taught them to think that
way
the movies are the opposite all the
better games the movie industry actually
works in many ways the opposite of that
because i i do a fair number of films as
well and i've looked up
movies of mine on imdb where the
publicly listed budget is probably five
times
what it actually costs to make really
because they're they're posturing
up uh to say you know like as they try
to go like if it's an independent film
and they're trying to sell to a
distributor
they want to look as expensive as
possible and so they'll they'll just
outright lie
and say or they'll they'll budget for
you know in kind
they'll say well this actor gave us you
know a day rate
but they normally would charge 10 times
that so we're going to go ahead and list
the 10 times
rate because that was an in-kind you
know exchange that sort of thing
and so but then the reverse starts to
happen as you get into the really high
budget like i i
once was um uh
i'll leave details out of the story but
i was once at the table on an
interesting film
where they they uh were
internal conversations with they were
spending well over a hundred million
dollars on this film and then it ended
up coming out i did not work on the film
it ended up coming out and making
it bombed hard and so if you go look up
the budgets now it's like oh you know 70
million 80 ml because the company is
trying to
for their investors and what they're
trying to depress the loss
that it looks like for them as much as
possible and so they're actually making
it look as
cheap as it could be and you see that
you know that
the only time i ever remember it being
in the marketing was when titanic came
out and because it was the highest
budget film of all time
at that time do you know what was before
by the way
no i have no idea true lies
freaking cameron huh expensive filmmaker
man he spends his money well
but it's true that it's true that the
perception of things expect like one of
the one of my big things i used to use
in pitches was that
we all like a lot of our early games
people thought were much expensive more
expensive to produce than they were and
and that was something publishers looked
for in us was
you can turn one dollar into two dollars
on screen that was something that had
value steven spielberg
steven spielberg is absolutely i love it
when you call me stephen
i call you stephen that's the beard um
no steven spielberg uh
has famously been like he he shoots his
master here and then he comes in here so
he shoots very
inexpensively so but he makes it look so
much bigger but he's just a really
really skilled and he does that because
he was a
guerrilla renegade filmmaker he's like i
don't have olin rogers the same way man
he
he knows how to make everything go up on
the screen and look bigger
than it really is um and that just comes
from
i don't have much i have i can make an
album with this and that's all that i
have
nick drake making pink moon one of the
greatest albums ever
and he did that on the fourth track and
the party being really cheap is also
often a talking point like
uh primer i always use as an example of
a movie that i tell people to watch in a
talking point is always
and only cost ten thousand dollars to
make yeah that is like a thing that you
bring up when talking about a movie like
primer as as an
as an asset like what they achieved with
ten thousand dollars is nuts but also
you should probably know that it was
really cheaply made
i think yeah paranormal fundamentally
proven my point wrong
that people talk about money way more
games than movies they shouldn't right
like they should
like it's not i don't know i think it's
interesting academically but like i
don't
i don't i think we over emphasize it as
a qualitative statement
so you know this game cost twice as much
as this game shouldn't be
something we worry about it should be
about the quality join us
next week as remy ismail takes mike
bithell's place
i was i was gonna i was just like adding
to that point of
that i think if i remember correctly the
most profitable film of all time was
paranormal
activity because it cost like a grand um
and made some outrageous like over 100
million or something
uh and um but but yeah that
it really is rarely part of the um
the conversation and i tend to agree
with you mike that
it's it is academically interesting and
as someone in the industry you know
especially as i try to cater
when working with somebody you know i
want to make sure that i don't have
blanket statements alana do you need to
run to the freezer in a steam room
back and forth really way to bring it
back eleanor generous
let's get it through the screen myself
please give me the
coca-cola yeah it's delicious and it
saves lives
it does it helps with asthma fun fact
any asthmatics out there cook helps
um this is an interesting episode
because i feel like we brought up a
topic and then we discussed all angles
of it and then we came to a conclusion
and the conclusion is
it varies is this podcast becoming
professional because that's not what i
like your tongue
bite your tongue i mean we had that bit
where i was laying down with the double
chin
not with your hair and beard that's true
that's fine we're gonna be just fine
um thank you everyone for joining us
live
uh to celebrate 20 episodes thank you to
everyone who supports the show i really
appreciate it you guys
uh are great it's still super positively
received and
i guess we haven't spoken about it but
the intention is to continue being
weekly for as long as we can
uh we'll see how that goes sorry about
my audio uselessness
that that was just so perfectly done
because it just [ __ ] up when you said
stuff absolutely perfect
god damn it
but in theory i should have austin's
full audio not on zoom
so the audio version will be fine well
well actually it's the opposite problem
i kept turning the gain up hoping that
would help so there's going to be all
kinds of distortion
i've done the same thing i am definitely
i've definitely made your life harder a
lot more i apologize enjoy the audio
version everybody
troy continues to be perfect thank you
troy everyone else is cancelled and
kicked off the show and replaced with
romney
that's right and jessica whose name i
pronounce wrong what is it
yes that's it yeah that was it those are
your friends
i believe is the surname as well